Sometimes it's good to sort of step back a
little bit and add some context to some of
them,
these fast moving stories that will consume
the news cycle for 24 hours or 48 hours.
Or in the case of the send them back chant
at a North Carolina Trump rally.
It's really been almost like a two week or
10 or 12 day story in total.
So remember last week at a rally in North
Carolina, Donald Trump mentioned congresswoman
Ilana Omar, the crowd starts chanting, send
her back.
Here's a quick reminder of what that was like.
[inaudible] you talked about the evil Israel,
so this completely implodes on Trump.
It really almost like five uninterrupted days
of criticism of the White House, which was
in full damage control mode.
Almost immediately found out about this from
the Washington Post article with 26 sources
about Trump didn't even really seem to understand
what it was that was problematic about what
went down and what he said and how he reacted
and what he tweeted.
So eventually it got through to Trump that
you probably want to distance yourself from
the chant at least.
So Trump took the position of I didn't like
the chat and in fact as as is always the case
with Trump, he goes too far.
He could say in retrospect, I didn't like
the chat, but he goes too far and says, I
tried to stop it right away.
I made super clear that I didn't like the
chant in the moment, which of course if you
look at the video is not clear whatsoever.
Check out what he said.
Again, this is just meaningless damage control.
Donald Trump trying to say anything that at
the time seems like it might help him.
And he says all sorts of stuff that just isn't
true, including that he started talking very
quickly.
So a MSNBC did a side by side with a counter
showing exactly how long it was that Trump
was silent.
As the chant continued.
Take a look,
just present, if I may.
When your supporters last night were challenging
chanting you send her back, why didn't you
stop them?
Why didn't you ask them to stop saying, well,
number one, I think I did.
I started speaking very quickly.
It really was.
I disagree with it by the way, but it was
quite a chance and I felt a little bit badly
about it, but I will say this, uh, I did and
I started speaking.
You can very quickly, but it started up rather
rather fast as you probably know.
Okay.
So he's telling us he didn't like the chant.
The chant was bad.
So he claims, but then Trump says, well, I
didn't like the chat, but the people chanting
are great people and are great patriots.
Where did we hear this before?
Heels.
Here's Donald Trump.
Not on the chant, but on the chanters.
I'm unhappy with the fact that a congress
woman, in this case, a different congress
woman can call our country and our people
garbage.
That's what I'm unhappy with.
Those people in North Carolina, that stadium
was packed.
It was a record crowd and I could have filled
a 10 times.
As you know, those are incredible people.
Those are incredible patriots, but I'm unhappy
when a congresswoman goes and said, I'm going
to be the president's nightmare.
By
the way, Trump said it was a record crowd.
What does that even mean at this point?
Obviously not true.
A demonstrable lie, one that Trump often likes
to tell, but there was nothing record breaking
about the crowd whatsoever, no matter how
you measure it, but the, the important thing
here is Trump says almost back to back.
He didn't like the champ.
He tried to stop the chat.
He resumed his speech quickly to interrupt
the chant, all of which are not true, but
then he also says the people in the crowd
doing the chanting, those are great people.
Those are patriots.
How does this compute?
The chant was disgusting and terrible.
The people who came up with the chant, truly
lovely, great patriots.
These are the sorts of contradictions that
come up when the president's word means nothing.
I mean, truly nothing.
Murder is absolutely disgusting.
It's terrible.
I don't know why anyone would ever commit
such a horrible act, but that room full of
murderers, those are great people.
I mean truly lovely, patriotic, great people.
The murders themselves though I disagree with
what are you talking about?
What are you talking about?
And it almost is like a philosophical discussion,
which couldn't possibly be with Donald Trump
is trying to stimulate here because the guy
has no clue about philosophy whatsoever.
It's, it's more like a reverse.
Double Down, send her back, looks pleased
in the moment, lets it go on reaction to send
her back as disastrous for Trump.
He says, I didn't like the chant, I interrupted
the chat quickly, which isn't true.
But then it gets us to say, oh, okay, so you're
upset with the people who were chanting, right?
Because you didn't like the chat.
Oh No.
The problem's not the people.
The people were great.
Uh, it was a record sized crowd full of patriots.
But the chant is what I disagree with for
all of the opposition to postmodernism, that
this new right claims to have, they sure to
seem, seem to see language and words as having
completely malleable fluid, meaning that can
be shaped like clay to mean or not mean whatever
it is that's convenient to them at the time.
Complete and utter contradiction.
If you care about double standards, if you
care about consistency, you're probably already
not voting for Donald Trump.